yep always reading fire yeah
what are you playing mustard Simon Peter
and Justin and then no nope
yeah okay uh that's a big guy
yeah he's actually all the smaller ones
yeah
[Music]
no that was a heck of a fight through
the engine and means business
yeah it does so I still did not get a
fan that I need to get that one is there
any way to like increase your chances of
getting that one item I think if I hit
him in the head hit up the Fang fight
him or fight him more times yeah I mean
that seems to be the loop so far and
definitely like playing with you guys is
helping me realize that like that's okay
because so much of this is a learning
experience and I'm still trying to learn
a lot thirty hours in and I still feel
like Oh Angie dance does that okay how
the hell do I prepare for that
[Music]
as a person who loves the series and has
always wanted to get more and more
people into it is that it it definitely
does a good job of kind of easing newer
people into it like like you it's a kind
of sort of understand stuff as you go
but it also still doesn't give up the
complexity that Monster Hunter has
always had so like I still feel really
good playing in and I can bring more
friends in to play it yeah which is what
you really want to do with a game like
this so it's like this is my first
monster on earth and I've always been
nervous because it's like it has this
reputation of like it'll take you dozens
about 70 hours to look like you is it to
finally understand Monster Hunter and
like you know this game like keeps
adding more layers to it over time but
within like 30 minutes I'm like I got a
sword I'm fighting I'm killing a monster
I'm like oh I get this this makes sense
like there I think from that perspective
it seems like they've it's not a scarier
as intimidating and assertive past games
like really like I want to keep playing
that makes me want to get
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a weird cycle I guess and that it's
kind of the same thing over and over but
the kind of flavor different every time
or to kind of keep you interested but it
gets better I mean you know you have
more monsters coming but like they add
more complexity I feel like to just like
the overall challenge where like the
beginning monsters are very easy like
you can kind of sort of stumble your way
through where it's like as long as I
know like basic combos and what I'm
doing you can fight those mobsters but
it could get further in like it's just
like oh I really need to think about
this I need to like consult my manual
and like feel like this guy has a blight
so I need an old berries and I need to
bring this particular thing and yeah I'm
kind of really slowly learning that
stuff I don't think the game does a
really excellent job of saying like do
you need to figure out a monster's
weakness you should consult this thing
it doesn't really doesn't tell you to do
it now I had to kind of discover this
resource which is fine because now I
know it's there yeah but I wonder like
okay what else am I missing but I guess
it's all part of a learning process it's
definitely a thing that Monster Hunter
like classically hasn't done very well
in that it literally won't tutorial like
anything does that on purpose you think
maybe - I hope but I feel like this one
does a pretty good job and it's one of
my favorite parts about it it does a
good job of kind of bringing people in
and easing them into the idea of what
Master Hunter is with that like there
are a lot of really good quality of life
changes if they're made in this game
that I really appreciate as a person
who's played like older ones yeah I mean
certainly telling me that like hey you
need to look for tracks yeah you know
where to find a monster and you need to
look for this stuff because you need to
craft items exactly and yeah like having
tried other ones in the past since the
first month around with Scout flies
right like
yeah it's like those neon things that
project out from you and lure you to the
points of entry look at that that's made
a huge difference even if I don't think
I'm accomplishing anything big I'm
accomplishing these little things
everywhere I go good
you're turning up a lot of clues you
actually feel like you're tracking
something now as opposed to like the old
one you'd have to like walk around all
the zones until you found it then you
had to paintball it and then it would
only stay there for like a 15 minutes
you can track her on that way or wave to
a balloon that's off in the distance and
they would mark it for you and this is I
mean how many have been multiplayer
Closter Hunter was not always I feel
like we've all been walking they've all
been multiplayer maybe just more like
local Justin's nodding his head and just
call the multiplex in yep yeah that's
that's the whole basis of Monster Hunter
is playing the friends
[Applause]
[Music]
alright i wanna i got like 30 minutes
because indeed one more Monster hun
alright let's do it yeah Erica
[Music]
[Music]